Fui aceptada en la Universidad Pepperdine
y volví a la misma escuela a la que asistí
para ser asistente de educación especial.
Y luego les dije: "Quiero ser profesora".
Y decían: "¿Qué? ¿Por qué?
¿Por qué quieres hacer eso?"
Así que empecé mi carrera docente
en exactamente la misma escuela secundaria a la que asistí,
y realmente quería tratar de salvar a más niños
que estaban igual que yo.
Y así, cada año, comparto mi experiencia con los niños,
porque necesitan saber que todo el mundo tiene una historia,
todo el mundo tiene una lucha,
y todos necesitamos ayuda en el camino.
Y yo voy a ser su ayuda en el camino.
Como profesora novata creé oportunidades.
Un día vino un niño a mi clase
que fue apuñalado la noche anterior.
Le dije: "Tienes que ir a un hospital,
a la enfermera de la escuela, algo".
Me dijo: "No, señorita, no iré.
Tengo que estar en clase porque necesito graduarme".
Sabía que yo no iba a dejar que él fuera una víctima
de su circunstancia,
pero nosotros íbamos a seguir adelante y seguir avanzando.
Y esta idea de crear un refugio seguro para nuestros hijos
y llegar a saber exactamente lo que están enfrentando,
a conocer a sus familias... yo quería eso,
pero no podía hacerlo en una escuela con 1600 alumnos,
y profesores que cambian año, tras año, tras año.
¿Cómo se llegan a construir esas relaciones?
Así que creamos una nueva escuela.
Creamos
el Instituto San Fernando de Medios Aplicados.
Y nos aseguramos de estar todavía apegados
a nuestro distrito escolar por financiamiento y apoyo.
Pero con eso, ganaríamos libertad:
libertad para contratar a los profesores
que sabíamos serían efectivos;
libertad de controlar el plan de estudios,
para no tener que hacer la lección 1.2, de la página 5;
y libertad para controlar el presupuesto,
para gastar dinero donde más importa
y no donde un distrito o estado dice que lo hagas.
Queríamos esas libertades.
Pero cambiar todo un paradigma
no ha sido un camino fácil, y ni siquiera completo.
Pero teníamos que hacerlo.
Nuestra comunidad merecía una nueva forma de hacer las cosas.
Y como la primera secundaria piloto
de todo el Distrito Escolar Unificado de Los Ángeles,
créanme que hubo oposición.
Y fue por temor...
temor a, bueno, ¿y si se equivocan?
Sí, ¿y si nos equivocamos?
¿Y qué tal si acertamos?
Y acertamos.
Así que a pesar de que los profesores estaban en contra
porque contratamos por año...
si no puedes enseñar, o no quieres enseñar,
no puedes estar en mi escuela con mis niños.
(Aplausos)
¿Cómo nos fue en nuestro tercer año?
Bueno, hacemos que valga la pena venir a la escuela cada día.
Hacemos que los niños sientan que son importantes para nosotros.
Hacemos que nuestro plan de estudios sea riguroso y relevante para ellos,
y ellos usan toda la tecnología a la que están acostumbrados.
Portátiles, computadoras, tabletas... lo que sea, lo tienen.
Animación, programas para hacer películas, todo.
Y conectamos todo a lo que están haciendo.
Por ejemplo, hicieron anuncios de servicio público
para la Sociedad del Cáncer
que se anunciaron en el sistema de tranvías local.
Enseñamos elementos de persuasión,
no hay nada más real que eso.
Nuestros resultados en las pruebas estatales han mejorado
más de 80 puntos desde que nos convertimos en nuestra propia escuela.
Pero todos los interesados han tenido que trabajar juntos:
profesores y directores en contratos de un año,
dedicando muchas más horas al trabajo que las del contrato
sin compensación.
Y se necesita un miembro del consejo escolar
que vaya a presionar en nombre de uno y diga:
"Sabes, el distrito trata de imponer esto,
pero tienes la libertad de hacer otra cosa".
Y se necesita un centro activo de padres de familia
que no solo esté allí, mostrando su presencia a diario,
sino que sea parte de nuestro gobierno,
tomando decisiones por sus niños, nuestros niños.
Porque, ¿por qué tienen los estudiantes
que alejarse tanto de sus hogares?
Se merecen una escuela de calidad en su barrio,
una escuela a la que puedan sentirse orgullosos de asistir,
y una escuela de la que también la comunidad pueda estar orgullosa,
y los alumnos necesitan profesores que luchen por ellos a diario
y les den el poder para sobreponerse a sus circunstancias.
Porque es hora de que niños y niñas como yo
dejen de ser la excepción, y sean la regla.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)